pendant ce temps à chinon pauline
poursuit son odyssée du patrimoine
rabelaisien donc là on est dans la rue
rabelais c'est ça oui dans la rue
rabelais lors il faut dire qu'elle
chinon il ya la rue rabelais il ya le
cinéma rabelais il y a le lycée rabelais
la statue de rabelais à ce moment de l'
aventure il serait bon de ramener
pauline dans sa zone de confort
on va la perdre au bout de la rue
rabelais nous allons trouver une
boulangerie pâtisserie qui fait les
fouaces comme à l'époque de rabelais
donc la recette un peu évolué
certainement mais on sait que la recette
est donné dans un van toi et comme dans
gargantua la fois ses généreuses 400
calories par portion
je vous en prie je laisse pas libre
[Musique]
alors il montrait mois alors elle est
composée d'une pâte
une sorte de pâte briochée avec des noix
du miel de la cannelle on est toujours
mais sera toujours là on va partager
voila voila tout à fait vous montre un
petit peu parce qu'après donc c'est
vraiment une petite brioche
[Musique]
un petit déjeuner c'est formidable c'est
ce que j'allais dire ça ça ce sujet est
donc cette fois ce dans l'histoire de
rabelais qu'elle plaçait alors la fouace
c'est l'élément qui va déclencher la
guerre collins idéal que vous avez les
bergers qui sont assez dans la vigne que
l'on a vu tout à l'heure
et puis les fois ci les boulangers qui
naît de l'ernée vendre leur foi ça
chinon et donc y'a des fois ci qui
demande à acheter la fouace au boulanger
refus de vente et le refus de vente
engendre une bagarre qui engendre la
guerre picrocholine et après les guerres
picrocholines place à la guerre d'hugo
traiteur charcutier traiteur
voilà qui est sur la même petite place
place mirabeau
à ma droite pauline ambassadrice
tartelettes et orfèvre en pâtisserie
face à elle l'élément gastronomique
principal de la littérature épicurienne
bonjour madame
la charcuterie et son cochon voltigeurs
il va falloir tendre sur soi tout ce qui
est cochonnailles est très présent dans
l'oeuvre de rabelais je vais vous
laisser goûter parce que moi
personnellement je ne mange pas de
viande depuis un petit bout de temps
maintenant
score sans appel rillettes 1 pauline 0
rabelais quand il évoque l effet de
faire l'amour il dit également prendre
plaisir à se frotter la couenne à dakar
voilà donc on est